hello everyone I'm a lot of welcome my
channel today we are just about to watch
live the ghosts of Tsushima stay to play
I am so excited to watch this I think
especially because this is one of the
few cases for me in video game marketing
where I feel like I've seen a bunch of a
game but I haven't seen it so much that
I'm bored of seeing it I still have a
lot of questions I know it's really
pretty I understand the setting I know
it's been my sucker punch who I love
which you know you could have sold me
without showing me anything of it on the
name alone but I still don't know that
much about how the game actually plays
which means it's not been oversaturated
which means I'm still very excited to
see more apparently we have roughly 45
seconds yes so hopefully we got a little
bit more of an understanding of what
Kombat looks like what traversal looks
like what a Quest looks like because I
have no idea of than it looks fluid and
beautiful and I can't wait
[Music]
so pretty one i'm jason canal from
sucker punch tracing we have a lot to
show you today about ghosting Tsushima
combat is this an engines asian special
modes but first let's take a look at how
you explore the world of Tsushima cool
onboard already show it to me
[Music]
a car
those end console cycle games just hit
different since the very beginning but
you can't have exploration if you don't
have curiosity
so we've continually asked ourselves is
this really how he's gonna long island
guide you in the most team at seriously
an immersive way is possible
I mean that's like a breath of wild
design he's talking about there was like
you see something in the distance and
you want to go to it
breath of the wild nailed that I felt
like not a lot of open-world games dude
that's why they rely so heavily I'm just
showing you custom markers on a map but
if this is more about like we won't play
this to see it in the world and then
want to go to it now we get using wind
does ever Thunder soon look at those
Cape physics bro damn
[Music]
are you gonna let me fly like a breath
with a while - because I'm on board ah
Kenny surf down the hill the grass is by
proxy baby allergies
alright cool we can call horses love
that man just getting those individual
blades of grass to look like they are
actually reacting to the wind must have
been so hard to develop like I don't
even really know how they've done it
[Music]
oh that's cool okay that's what they
mean by the wind is that you can get it
to guide you I guess streams not great
quality that's a boma
[Music]
the chat keeps saying it looks like a
huge downgrade are you joking get out of
here
[Music]
he was on a random event type thing
[Music]
like Red Dead style oh you can grab
bamboo while you're on horseback that's
cool
yeah I'm getting like a mix of like Red
Dead Redemption and breath of the wild
vibe sofa the guiding wind could take
you to all kinds of locations in the
game like this farmstead that's been
taken over by the Mongols it can also
take you to your next big story moments
or even help you find rare collectibles
what's cool but what about the things
that you don't know about you haven't
seen yet but you don't know exists it's
a smart way to like eyes peeled for
other visual cues keep the UI minimal on
the horizons interesting and gods shaped
trees or maybe even handles trying to
get your attention the directing people
via the wall itself against little like
breath of the wild rather than having
you play around in a menu as a la la
Ubisoft these days like just having a
million quest mock is to populate a map
they've actually populated the map with
big things and yet having the wind guide
you instead of having a waypoint or like
a trail or something is or even a mini
map like red Deadwood had on this neat
hmm buds will help to very cool yeah
it's a lot of effort in there making
this old cinematic the spirits of
vengeful samurai haunt this forest
[Music]
god it's just so pretty
shame the stream quality is not good
that's a ball mount but still looks
beautiful
[Music]
the music's gorgeous Oh get your sheets
and your supplies love love it both very
helpful
and you gonna be huntin
oh no they'll guide you I love that I
was I was gonna be sad about the Fox
dying yeah Billy he's a lot more at one
with nature than I anticipated
I love that the seamless like gathering
very good no it's a Fox trying okay it's
an upgrade system
[Music]
into it into it
[Music]
fast travel confirmed into it Sushma is
rich with exploration and discovery
whether you're just following a string
of torii gates that will lead you to a
high mountain shrine or maybe it's just
a fox trying to show you something
confirm Kemp's hat the dog doesn't quite
count as a dog but it will take it ten
toes and give it to you
really like that oh cool I mean you know
what to be fair if sucker-punch way ever
gonna be good at anything they good at a
lot of things there's gonna be
traversable they were gonna nail that
they know how to get players around a
wealth in an interesting way
post tail looks weird I remember
thinking that when I first so read that
game play damn look at that the lighting
the reflections beautiful I want to be
here damn see little pagoda it oh man
damn
hi this is Nate Fox from sucker punch
oh hi Nate I know Nate oh we just showed
you some exploration but let's switch
gears and check out some combat awesome
I saw Nate was actually uh at e3 talking
about this game he gave me a dream spin
he was hungover
drumbeat I think this is a soundtrack
I'm gonna want ever seen a samurai movie
you know what to expect
two warriors sizing each other up
waiting sighted sickness stand off first
it looks so much like for onna I keep
thinking that like maybe awesome to my
miss fauna it's so hard to see how this
plays by looking at it but I mean it
looks cool as hell but I don't know what
it feels like like as you can see the
Mongols are everywhere on this island
for Jin to succeed he has to use real
skillful precision okay no wasted energy
how does it right must you know very
nice I love a good stealth boat that was
cool okay so comment with multiple
enemies looks like it functions a bit
like Assassin's Creed where they do like
kind of wait for you but they have
different enemy types with different
weapon ranges sort of thing they're not
all coming at you at once yeah this sim
Assassin's Creed in hand I just want to
know what it feels like water States
interesting what there are different
stances for foreign enemy types
I just want to how complicated it feels
you know this it looks cinematic as hell
but how does it feel and I was kind of
hoping that today I would get an idea of
how the comb out feels to play but I
still don't feel like I really know I'm
getting Assassin's Creed akhom far on a
mixed together it's my guess and I like
all of those but it's still not entirely
sure who's gonna be about stealth maybe
okay so that was gin fighting as a
samurai but now let's see him take on
the same group of Mongols as the
dishonorable ghosts great as the ghost
he'll use every dirty trick you can
think up to even the odds cool even
using fear as a weapon I wonder if these
shipyards are like [ __ ] our outpost type
thing again pretty Assassin's Creed II
here so yeah maybe this is gonna be like
a take out the outpost situation you can
do it how you want to maybe it'll be a
bunch of them
but yeah I like the side-quests I'm
always down with this kind of thing
the lighting is stellar
I really like it
[Music]
wish this dream was about equality man
one day these big rich publishers are
gonna start streaming in 4k
[Music]
[Music]
I'm definitely gonna play this way it's
super into this yeah for sure it's
Assassin's Creed II yeah it looks like
most things on one-hit kill which I
don't think we've seen Jim take any
damage yet right here you smoke bombs
okay that was not one damn you still
gonna kill him I feel like I'd let that
one go new Oh interesting so like them
being afraid of you if you tact through
stealth as a mechanic that's really cool
I don't know that I've seen another game
do that that's very cool
like obviously other games have dialogue
where they'll be like oh I'm afraid of
this so whatever but um I'm actually
reacting that way in combat is supinate
feel like that was like part of what
made like those predator rooms in an
ahkam series so cool is like feeling
like you're powerful and you're taking
them out like a boss like what you're a
real predator and then like growingly
increasingly being nervous and you could
see their heart rate with the scanner
similar vibe
[Music]
but Allah
[Music]
lovely loving this music man it's I kind
of feel like this is like the Japanese
Assassin's Creed game everyone's been
wanting what was he doing there was this
something bad is it so dark that I can't
see what was he looking at what you do
but nice
oh she's gonna buy the whole thing down
school
I guess sup this I can see the chat I
wish I couldn't honestly but I don't
want to play with anything in case it
screws up the way it looks for you guys
but yeah the the chat is full of people
saying it's a downgrade I really don't
think it is a downgrade from anything
we've seen before no if anything it's
just stream qualities lacking you might
have noticed that well fighting the cool
samurai or sneaking around as the ghost
nice didn't head on a different set of
armor that's because I didn't were in
this game actually about gives you
different mechanical advantages sweets
not be jealous lookups accent your
chosen play style as you explore the
world you'll discover ohm amore charms
they'll give you an edge in battle but
more importantly as your legend grows
you'll develop all new techniques which
transform jinn from a samurai into the
ghost the thing is you get to decide how
those techniques evolved and great over
time it's always worth keeping an eye
out for die flowers find enough of them
and you can change the color of an armor
so not only do you get all smooth how
that ghost gameplay involves but you can
fine-tune the look as well
sounds great also been doing that for a
while but I loved it I really like that
you can get the AMA that suits your
playstyle but also make it look the way
you want like I find myself in mmo's all
the time wearing stuff that is weak or
doesn't fit my play style just because
photo mode oh just because I like the
way it looks mole it wouldn't be a
sucker punch game if it didn't happen
yes and our new photo mode we have
features such as color grading depth of
field all games launched with the photo
mode these days fam we have a bunch of
new features that we found fantasy
doesn't have ocean
and movement that's so great about our
game you can control the winds direction
the speed you can change out the
particles to different types of leaves
and fireflies in Countess odo tract of
music from our original score that might
be a little bit more fitting so if we
ended doing a photo maybe you actually
want to do a video there's something
here for you cool here's a few that I've
created
[Music]
goddamn man
we call the get a lot of gifts out of
this I think
[Music]
a Japanese voice track option with
subtitles is a perfect fit for our game
so I'm happy to say that before the
first scene even starts you'll be able
to turn this option on
I think I might play it with this
Japanese voice track I liked it in
Sakura but
here at sucker punch we are huge fans of
samurai cinema that's really cool create
a way for you to feel like you're
playing your favorite samurai movie so
we created a windy black-and-white film
grain down no way to turn on from the
very beginning of the game that's super
cool
hell yeah dude I love it
[Music]
I just want to know how it plays you
know it's like this this game more than
like most games is frustrating launch
combat off because I just don't have a
grasp on what it feels like and I want
to know so bad
I got sound a couple months away but
17th of July to be precise
dope
[Music]
today we've shared with you some of the
unique ways that you can explore the
island of Tsushima we've also shared
with you some of the ways you can fight
as a samurai or assassinate as the ghost
customized jinn these are all things I
like play in special ways but we have so
much more to show you in the future
ghosts of Tsushima comes out on July 17
thank you so much for watching today
you'll see you later you know so welcome
thank you thank you for having me I
guess my main thoughts on they saw
definitely a lot more Assassin's Creed
II than I expected when my big thing is
I just hope it's a little bit more
breath of the wild than Assassin's Creed
just because obviously we've had so many
Assassin's Creed's like that formulas so
familiar to me but it looks absolutely
stunning gameplay still looks awesome
really cinematic love the school I want
it I do want it give it to me thank you
guys watching let me know what you guys
thought